so i'm about to show you a video of me
at 21 22 years old which a friend shared
with me a year and a half ago i'd never
seen this i know whose house it was in
it was an old friend davine's house
after a message i just gave i just got
out of the army i'm broke 49k in that i
have no clue what's going on
and i'm sick of it and the guy asked me
a question well i'll just let you watch
this video and look at the reaction so
here's me
22 year old pat this is 2001. mark my
words by the time
most definitely just because of teamwork
so we have a ridiculous team going on
you know it's crazy
uh when i see this uh uh uh and i'm
acting all confident i got a lot of
fears on the inside at that time and
securities whether i can pull it off or
not but at the same time
i got big dreams i i just can't imagine
living a small life but i got the fear
at the same time it's almost as if you
need the requirement of a person who has
big plans i think i can pull this off
but internally you're so scared you're
so insecure your self-esteem is like man
maybe i can't pull this thing off maybe
i can but in this phase when i look at
this here's all i think about
um
i remember watching uh matthew
mcconaughey give a speech an acceptance
speech when he said you know who you're
going after and he talked about the fact
that i'm going after the 45 year version
of me 55 year old version of me all the
stuff that he was explaining
to me
it's the other way around and let me
explain to what i mean by this
we all have heroes a lot of are here
like one of my heroes is my dad okay
i got heroes that are in the military i
got heroes that are
movie figures fictional figures but we
got heroes you got heroes but i'm gonna
tell you one of the biggest heroes of my
life and i think you got to be thinking
about it for yourself
one of my biggest heroes is this guy
okay
when i look at this guy because this 22
year old pbd when i look at him he was
this close from joining the army
he was this close from throwing the
towel he's going through a very very
ugly breakup it ain't pretty no one
knows it he's keeping it to himself
he's
he's like lost privately by people he
looks like he's got everything under
control by himself he has nothing under
control
but somehow someway
with all the distractions and girls
pulling in this direction friends
co-pulling in this direction
partying drugs gambling everything
around you
i am where i'm at because of the
decisions he made i'm not where i'm at
because what the decisions i made today
at 43
i'm where i'm at at 43 because of what
this guy did at 22.
this is my hero
okay now here's what's crazy
the other way around
the 63-year-old path 20 years from now
is watching to see what decisions i'm
going to make and i want to be that
guy's hero
i want him to one day be watching
valuetainment reacting to the videos i'm
making today and for him to say man i'm
so proud of the 43 year old pbd
i'm proud of what he's doing today
because how he all of a sudden handled
all the success that came his way he was
doing good and he made some money and
then he made money and then he made some
real money but because he handled
success the way he did this is why we're
here now i'm so proud of him and there's
got to be an emotional moment with that
so what does this mean to you who's your
hero you may say your mom your dad your
uncle
a sports figure a military figure an
author a president somebody you look up
to well
you definitely have to think about
you
being the hero
of the person you're going to be 20
years from now you want that person
that's 20 years older than what you are
today to be looking at you today saying
man
i'm so proud of them by the way you know
i've seen that thing if you when the guy
sent it to me the first time when marvin
sent me that video for the first time
and i looked at it i got emotional i'm
like freaking a
i remember you kid
i remember you i remember i could i
could go straight into the house and
tell you who was in that house
i can tell you where this was
angelo you know burbank off of gl i mean
i can tell you vividly i went there i'm
like i remember that day
and then from there the you know series
of events that takes place so anyways
for you
um
when you think about this
i hope it fires you up you know the
saying like when people say when your
dad says i'm proud of you when your mom
says i'm proud of you i never thought
the value of having myself saying to me
i'm proud of you
would mean as much as it means today as
a 43 year old grown man with four kids
and i'm running 10 businesses
i never thought it would mean that much
and so for you if you're seeking down
proudly from your mom from your dad
be just as
curious and interested in hearing it
from your mom and dad as you are to hear
it from the older version of you one day
to say i'm proud of the decisions you're
making today and these uncertain times
so if you got value from this video and
i got you thinking give it a thumbs up
and subscribe and i got a message i want
you to watch
i was given this message i want to say
it's in vegas there's about 1500 people
in the audience and the message is about
will versus want if you've never seen
this
click here to watch it it's gonna get
you thinking all day take care everybody
bye